- We've got a great show, everybody.
And it all starts up on our roof.
That's right.
We are in beautiful Southern California.
So we are taking advantage of the weather
and staying even safer during the surge,
by hosting some of our guests up there,
we did it with Chris Kattan yesterday
and it was so awesome, it was fun.
It felt like a date,
but cool, I'm into it.
So let's set it up right now
for another Interview Alfresco.
Jason, can you give me
like an extra long sting
while I run upstairs?
Like I'm in heels, like a long-
(medieval music)
Yeah, yeah.
Okay, here we go, here we go.
(upbeat medieval music)
All right,
and just like that,
I'm on the roof, y'all.
These guests are very funny.
You've seen one in The
Office and The Hangover
and the other in a few Marvel
Cinematic Universe projects.
Their new show is True
Story with Ed and Randall
streaming on peacock.
It's Ed Helms and Randall Park.
(Kelly imitates air horn blaring)
What's up y'all?
We can't touch, we can't
touch but we can do this.
(Kelly, Ed and Randall laughing)
Have a seat.
- All right, I love this.
- We have a new thing
we're trying to like,
keep it even safer.
Like we're outside.
- [Ed] It's terrific.
- [Randall] Yeah.
- [Kelly] Yes, yes.
- Are this real waters?
- These are, this isn't real water,
there's no real water.
We actually don't have anything for you.
It's just a really beautiful table.
We will bring water out now (laughs).
So we, this is our Cafe Alfresco.
That's what we're calling it.
But how long have you known each other?
It feels like your chemistry,
you have known each other forever.
- We, we were married.
(Kelly laughs)
- We're twins.
We're actually twins.
- You are married?
- We, yeah.
- We're fraternal twins.
- Twins and married, it's happening.
- We were, uh, we were
friends for a long time,
we lost touch and then we were reunited
at Beyonce's birthday.
- [Randall] That's right.
- Right.
- Because that's where we hang out.
- [Kelly] Is that a true
story at Beyonce's birthday?
Okay. I was like, you're
so much cooler than me.
Wait, what?
I was like-
- No, the real story is a lot
more fascinating actually.
We like just kind of met
each other here and there.
(Kelly laughs)
- Yeah, and, and can't
even trace the origin.
It's been a lot of years.
- I love that though.
Well, you have great chemistry.
That's what I love.
I saw you all recently on the voice,
on the last season and y'all are so funny.
It's just so yeah, I love it.
I love y'all's chemistry.
But The Office had a huge comeback,
like this, like the last several years,
I think has streaming.
Like everybody, like all those shows
that maybe were popular years
ago are coming back around.
Is that cool?
To like have a whole new fan base for it?
- It's totally insane and, and,
and mind blowing, honestly,
like there are kids who
weren't even born when,
when the shows started,
who are now like avid fans
and it's a, it's a thrill.
- 'Cause it's a great show.
- Yeah, it's totally, totally amazing.
Randall was on The Office.
- [Kelly] I know.
- I did an episode and it's crazy
because I think once-
- It's that what you meant?
That's what I thought, but
it apparently it wasn't.
But I did, I did one scene in one episode,
I was in and out in like a couple hours.
That's part, that one scene is probably
the thing I'm recognized the most for.
(Kelly and Ed laugh)
- You know that's how powerful you are.
(Randall laughs)
- It makes our show True
Story an Office reunion.
- [Kelly] It does.
- [Randall] That's right.
- So in The Office you
did a lot of acapella.
And like I mentioned on
the voice you came back
and you were on the voice
and I know you kick
John out of your group,
but Blake is now a member
of your acapella group.
- Yeah, of course.
We have an Ariana, the whole gang,
everybody's in the group.
- Just not John.
- Except for John.
(Kelly and Randall laugh)
Yeah, John and I have a,
we've been rivals for decades.
- [Kelly] Yeah, yeah.
- [Randall] Yeah, yeah.
- [Kelly] It makes sense.
- Since Beyonce's party.
- [Kelly] Since Beyonce's party (laughs).
- [Ed] But yeah, I've done-
- Since we have an acapella
off at Beyonce's party.
- Oh, that's right, of course.
- Did you grow up, though, really like
singing acapella, like in groups?
- No, not acapella per se, but I was like,
kind of like a choral nerd.
- [Kelly] I was too.
- Yeah, okay.
So like singing all the time.
My buddy Warren Goodrich
and I sang More Than Words
at a high school pep rally,
which doesn't even sound cool.
I think we thought it was
cool to do that, but it-
- I still think it's cool
which is why I was the nerd.
- I'm still proud of it.
But I think, I think that
technically it was not cool.
And that's what part, that's
part of what makes me not cool
is that I don't agree with that.
I still think it's cool.
- I still think it's cool.
What, what were your first concerts?
Like your experience since
you love music so much?
- My first concert,
I was invited to this concert
I abandoned that I didn't-
- You already feel,
you already feel like a lo-
- I apologize for it.
(Kelly, Ed and Randall laugh)
But no, but it is like,
since you're asking my first concert,
I was like, yeah, sure, I'll go.
The band was The Hooters.
Does it, do you remember this band?
- [Kelly] Is it like the
band for the restaurant?
The wings?
- [Ed] No, no, no.
Okay.
Great valid questions.
- [Kelly] Valid.
- But they were like kind of,
they had like a couple of hits
in the late eighties, I think.
And they were touring like small venues
by the time I was in high school
and we went and it was super fun.
And the drummer at one
point threw his drumsticks
into the crowd.
I caught one.
(Kelly laughs)
- Oh, wow.
- I got, I got a drumstick from the cons
from my very first time.
- You still have it to this day?
- I probably lost it that night.
I have no idea what happened.
(Kelly and Randall laugh)
- It was precious.
What was your first-
- [Randall] My first
concert was very cool.
- What was it?
- It was a well, this was
a, I was a kid, Harry Co-
I just, I decided Harry Connick Jr.
- [Kelly] Yeah, oh.
- But When Harry Met Sally had come out,
I was obsessed with that movie
and the music in the movie
and Harry Connick Jr. did a
big part of the soundtrack.
- [Kelly] He's great.
- And yeah, and I would just
love the soundtrack so much
and me and a friend found
out he was playing in Vegas.
We, we grew up in LA
and I begged my dad to,
to take us there and-
- You begged your dad
to take you (laughs).
- And he drove me and my
friend to Vegas and we just.
- Your dad took you to
Vegas to see a show?
- [Randall] Yeah.
- You have a cool dad.
- [Randall] Very cool of him, yeah.
- Okay, I was like, I just
love that it was usually like,
not like someone that,
usually it's like a pop band,
like boy, like, oh, I was just looking
into a different scenario.
- What you're saying? What
are you trying to say?
- No, I just mean usually
it was like, you were,
you had a very sophisticated
musical palette.
- [Randall] Yeah.
- [Ed] I agree, I agree.
- I got there, i got that.
(Randall and Kelly laugh)
- How old were you?
- Oh gosh, I must say, maybe
like early high school.
- I just mean like people would be like,
can you take me to Janet Jackson?
Can you take me-
Like and you're like please,
please Harry Connick Jr.
He's amazing.
I just love that, like, as a kid.
- You were like, can we go to the LA Phil?
(Kelly and Randall laugh)
- Please, please.
(Randall laughing drowns out Kelly)
- I must see it.
(Kelly laughs)
I'd love that.
- January is national soup month.
I didn't even know all these
things existed before the show,
but it's fascinating to find
out and I happen to love soup.
So everyone knows now that
this is national soup month.
Since we're at our roof cafe,
we have our favorite soups to share.
So check out this fancy soup tasting flat
of all our favorites.
And tell us about your
favorite before we dive in.
What's your favorite?
- All right, so, this is my favorite.
It's Mulligatawny soup.
- [Kelly] That is fancy.
- Yeah, which is an Indian soup.
The reason that I love it is because
it was on an episode of Seinfeld
and I think it was the soup Nazi episode.
- Oh, wait, is this the one
"No soup for you next time" line is?
Oh, my God.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
And I used to work near the
guy that it was based on,
the actual guy, and I went and I was like,
I got to go get the
Mulligatawny soup there,
which I think was Kramer's favorite,
and it instantly became my favorite.
It's so good.
- Oh my gosh, I love that backstory.
- [Ed] Yeah.
- And now I feel like mine's
not going to be as cool.
I love French onion soup
just 'cause it tastes good.
- [Ed] It's good
- Kay, Ed?
And I don't have like a really cool story
about a French person that
told me about it or anything.
I just like it.
No, I love it.
It's the best.
And I feel like when
you're, you would get this,
I traveled so much,
especially in my twenties,
like everywhere in the world.
And I feel like always on the menu,
there would be French
onion soup and it was like,
in case you just felt like
you didn't want to risk it
on something maybe, you were
in like Thailand or something,
you're like, I don't know,
I don't, I can't afford to
get sick before the show.
So I'd get French onion soup.
That's my thing.
- Amazing.
- I love French onion soup,
but my favorite is the Split Pea Soup.
- [Kelly] I've never had this.
- Yes.
I grew up going to Jewish
delis with my family
and I remember one that
we'd always go to an order,
always ordered the split pea.
To this day. I live in Studio City
or Art's Deli shout out
to Art's Deli on Ventura.
I ordered the split pea.
It's my favorite because it looks healthy.
It feels like it could be healthy.
- [Kelly] It's like not? (laughs)
- It's probably really bad for you.
- It's hardy.
- It's a hardy situation.
- Yes.
- Okay.
- It's really good.
- But you think it's
healthy because it's green.
- Okay, I want to try your,
I want to try your soups.
So I'm trying.
Okay and I'm trying this one first.
I don't even know, Mulligatawny?
- [Ed] Hm.
- Okay.
That's really good.
- Wow, that is good.
- Yeah.
This is a good, this is a good one too.
- That's a step up.
Yeah, that's really nice.
I already know I love this,
but I just want to try it.
I mean, no one messes
up French onion soup.
That's what I'm saying.
That's why it's a go-to.
- And it comes with a big glob of cheese.
- Exactly.
And bread, like a giant crouton.
- If you love pizza, you
gonna love this soup.
- [Kelly] Who doesn't love pizza?
- It's like liquid pizza.
- [Randall] Yeah.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
Okay, I'm trying yours.
There's like a little cream thing on it.
Oh my gosh.
That's really good.
- [Randall] Yeah, right?
- I've never had, so if
somebody would have said,
do you wanna split pea soup?
I would have said absolutely not.
And now that I've had
it, that's really good.
- Yeah, ain't it?
- It's almost like, is there bacon in it?
- There's bacon in it, yeah.
- Okay.
That's the text, the texture I mean,
something's in it that
I'm like, I like it.
- That's the thing, that's the key.
- [Kelly] Okay, okay.
- [Ed] Oh, yeah.
- So wait, let's talk about your show.
So it's called true story
with Ed and Randall.
So what's the, tell everybody the premise.
- So it's kind of a hybrid
unscripted scripted show.
Basically Randall and I sit
down with real everyday people
who have incredible
stories from their lives
and they're true stories.
Randall and I have never
heard the story before,
we interview them about the
story, we get the whole tale,
it's a really fun conversation and then-
- And then we give them,
basically, their own bio pic.
We, we do a reenactment of the stories.
We get our celebrity friends
and great comedians to play
the characters in the story,
including the storyteller.
- Oh my gosh.
- And yeah, and we, we kind of give them
that the story the special
treatment and it's just fun.
- So it is like funny stories
that you people get to reenact?
Are some of them like serious?
- It's really variety.
Like, what's incredible about the show
and what I didn't even expect going in
is how moving a lot of it is.
Like, they're all funny in some way,
but some of them are like
poignant or heartbreaking
or just like very uplifting,
I mean, very moving.
And that's what's I think
what really is special
about the show, like it's just
human connection happening,
in real time.
- And the storytellers
themselves are just so,
they're so different from one another.
- [Ed] Yeah.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- You have some like, really great-
- So you have the original person
that happened to be telling the story,
but then you have like
other people acting it out.
- Yeah, it's like-
- Playing like they were kids
or when they were, you know,
like earlier in their life.
- That's so cool.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Oh my gosh.
I didn't know that that
was all in purpose.
That is so cool.
And so interesting and so
different from anything else.
And I love a reenactment.
- [Ed] Yeah.
- I do, especially when it's fun (laugh).